hey guys quick video for you today I
thought that I would copy Rachel from
the ox blog project in doing the TMI tag
originally created by Carrie hope
Fletcher if you haven't seen that
channel by the way go and check out what
if I hadn't seen either those channels
go and check them both out links in the
description what are you wearing I am
wearing my keep calm and carry a towel
t-shirt given to you got my parents and
my trackies because I probably not going
to leave my room today because I'm
working well meant to be ever been in
love yes
never had a terrible breakup yeah how
tall are you
I am a shade over 6 foot tall how much
do you weigh last time I checked about
76 kilos any tattoos nope any piercings
nope OTP Zoey and wash
favorite show of all time Firefly that
I'm currently watching Breaking Bad
favorite band queen gorillas Coldplay
Eminem Ed Sheeran
something you miss my cap Henry favorite
song probably for crying out loud by
meatloaf how old are you 23
and a month zodiac sign Libra quality
you look for in a partner
empathy geekiness intelligence you
played timesplitters that really helps
favorite quote it's actually a quote of
a quote which is in one of my favorite
books of all times any art of motorcycle
maintenance favorite actor you Jan of
course what is your favorite color red
loud music or soft music most of the
time loud music where do you go when
you're sad how long does it take you to
shower um I've never timed it I guess
five minutes I mean how long can it take
how long does it take you to get ready
in the morning I am really not a morning
person for the best part now ever been
in a physical fight there's new someone
in the balls count as a fight
turn on human turn off lack of
intelligence the reason you joined
YouTube I want to help people who were
applying stalks bridge and to try and be
an advice figure that I never have an
answer play fears crabs and lobsters
and most marine and arthropods frankly
the last thing that made you cry
probably when I watched Toy Story 3
again like 9 or 10 months ago
their gravity nearly mimicked right the
last time you said you loved someone
were my best mate John Cayley on a visit
what's the meaning behind your youtube
name Simon Oxford physics the last book
you read the last book I read completion
was the visual display of quantitative
information by Edward Tufte the book
you're currently reading I'm one of
these awful people that has like several
books on the go
at any one time so I'm currently reading
rereading Zener the art of motorcycle
maintenance and this really interesting
book on mindset which actually I'll
leave a link to in the description
because it's some such they've been a
very very interesting read my supervisor
gave me this thank you Mark what was the
last show you watched Star Trek The Next
Generation unless you count the Alex
cast I don't think that really counts a
TV show but that's the last thing I
watched who was the last person you
talked to my girlfriend the relationship
between you and the last person you
texted my friend David who lives on my
street and whom we talked to one another
in glossy er if anybody knows what that
is
Talan Misha storm favorite food my mum's
spinach and chickpea curry why do you
want to visit I really want to travel
loads in my life and I love seeing new
places new cultures but me and John was
specifically talking about going to
China at some point there's a city code
lay Shan and there's a think of the
leshan giant buddha which is the largest
pre-modern statue in Scituate where was
the last place you were the white
company next er I was singing in the
harmonics a capella group we were doing
some carols for their big opening thing
do courage me and girlfriend both agreed
it's okay for us to both fancy Jennifer
Lawrence and Hugh Jackman
when was the last time you kissed
someone yesterday when was the last time
you were insulted I genuinely can't
remember
probably a comment on a YouTube one way
each if it is to be honest favorite
flavor of sweet Wren what instruments do
you play
I sing allegedly I play saxophone alto
and the ukulele and I'm teaching myself
the piano
favorite piece of jewelry do wrist bands
count as jewellery what was the last
sport you played
there's Jim count as a sport
I've been weight lifting is technically
a sport the last song you sang
springtime month left every bow which is
a 16th century piece by the composer
thomas morley it sounds a little bit
like this the shares for the console
favorite chat-up line Hey you sat on f5
because that ass is refreshing every
used it I'm a physicist of course though
last time you hung out with anyone I
guess in the strictest terms it would
have been when John came down and we
hang out watching the Doctor Who 50th
anniversary special and South Park who
should answer these questions next Jamie
I would really like Jamie Jamie Mills to
answer these questions because everyone
in the Oxbow project is going to do
these and I'd like to learn a bit more
about you Jamie because I feel like I
don't necessarily know you that well so
that's it just a quick video if you guys
and i will be doing some scientific
stuff quite soon leave it like if you
like this video by the way and I will
possibly do more of this kind of thing
I'm gauging what kind of content to do
based on the response from you guys so
do let me know what you like and what
you don't like